our next web heroes take nature into
their own hands
harnessing the awesome power of the wind
to do this
I find it fascinating that really small
movements result in such dramatic
changes of heights and directions the
sole fliers are truly in their element
at this skydiver area in Prague but how
does a wind tunnel release them from the
grip of gravity they need to be able to
create an equilibrium that's gonna
counteract their weight due to gravity
and the wind has to be strong enough to
overcome their weight this chamber
blasts air at up to a hundred sixty-five
miles per hour to get the SOL Flyers
flying but how do they pull off these
phenomenal flips and turns found a
surface area that allows the air to push
against them and keep them nice and
stable roughly in the middle now if they
changed their size their shape their
surface area will either get smaller or
bigger and this will vary the amount of
air molecules that come push against so
if they get smaller if they change their
surface area you know they might go
vertical there's less area less space
the air molecules to push against them
they're gonna go down because there
isn't as large a force pushing on them
so if gravity is gonna win that
tug-of-war slightly more they make
themselves bigger there's more air
molecules pushing against them and
basically they start kind of winning out
against gravity and they go pop they've
clearly spent a lot of time in this wind
tunnel when they leave they don't just
kind of awkwardly float down and walk
out do do a kind of phenomenal spin and
land on their feet on the way out and
that's crossing the line now they're
just showing off